uh being a female in comedy do you date
comedians or is that like because is
that like a musician dating a musician
you maybe should
exactly okay you should not because say
you're on the road together i know we're
in close quarters and you
something happens you get together but
now they can't go on the road with you
anymore
or you can't go on the road with them
because now they really you know it's
too much now you're working together
now when the girls come after the show
you're watching
no you cannot i okay if you do date a
comedian
you got to be able to pick which one's
going to make it
that's what you got to do like i missed
my shot with kevin hart
i didn't know he was smaller than me and
i was like kevin gone now back up
but i should have gone to a little
fortune teller i should have talked to
somebody a little psychic or something
and said
okay there's this little dude after me
and i like him but he little
uh what you think we're both in the same
business if they just said
one day he's going to have all this
jumanji money
yeah i'd have been right there talking
about coming you've come here yeah you
come here
i i love gabriel i love him too he's
funny
he's always been fun oh my god he's so
funny i just saw his recent stand-up
thing he just did
want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure